rece Davis back here on the show how are
you Rhys I'm doing great Rick how are
you so I'm great so we have a draft
where I believe the first overall
selection is just as stipulated and then
the drama begins second overall would
you agree with that Rhys I would now I
know that there are some reports today
that maybe the Kings are interested in
Luca Don judge I I still believe and I
could be wrong but I think that Martin
back with the serve will go second then
we don't know what's going to happen for
sure because the Hawks are talking about
trading down and you know who they want
it's a little bit of a mystery if they
were to stay in a third spot so I think
that really at threes when the
uncertainty will start although
certainly would shake things up a bit if
faculty were to still be available at
3:00 so then one two and three hits and
then it appears it appears the Memphis
Grizzlies have put that number for
overall pick on the block up for grabs
with anybody who thinks that mo Bamba
would be gone by the fifth overall
selection that you need to you need to
hit that trigger before
Mark Cuban gets his hands on on him what
are you hearing about that Reis from
what what we hear with our guys you know
we have Adrian was fourth down
he eats amazing in terms of Intel as
everyone knows but you know Memphis is
an organization right now that's having
to decide what direction they want to go
in as Gasol and Conley get a little bit
older and you know are they committed to
trying to find the right piece to go
with them the players want to go there
all of those types of things that
present challenges for them so I think
that they would be open if they could
get players to come back and allow
someone to take that spot and then maybe
get something that would fit within
trying to stay relevant for a few more
years after having missed the playoffs
you know long playoff run and in terms
of consecutive years making it then and
they've stumbled in that regard and I
think that kind of let's try to get it
together for one more run before they
break the thing down so now Reese Davis
joining me here on the Rich Eisen show
how are you planning on connecting the
free agency period to tonight's
proceedings
barring any trades that would make make
that that point A to point B an obvious
connect for you as the host reason you
know rich that's that's one of the
difficult things is because you do the
NFL draft and do it so very well and I
said in a meeting this morning that it
is one area in which the NFL is better
than the NBA in that meaning until you
know until the moratorium ends on July
6th some of these trades can't be
official until then they find out their
salary cap you'll have a number of
players tonight who are drafted by a
team but that that team who goes up and
calls the name of the player that's not
really the team drafting them for
instance last year eleven of the thirty
first round picks didn't play for the
team that drafted them you know in some
cases you know what's happening right
then as I recall we knew that that the
Nuggets were drafting Donovan Mitchell
for the Jazz but sometimes you don't and
it's uh you know that's that's the
confusing part and to answer your
question about it
that's where free agency plays and
everybody's going to be watching what
the Cavaliers do but the honest truth is
I understand about the Cavaliers have no
idea whether they are drafting someone
to compliment LeBron or if they are
drafting someone that they have the
perhaps will be the cornerstone of the
franchise if LeBron chooses to leave and
you know there's a very similar
situation in San Antonio right now with
Kawhi Leonard yeah I know that that was
part of a large part of confusion for me
watching the draft coverage last year
Reese was woge and everybody else would
say the trades in and this team has
swapped this player or these picks for
this pick and then I would watch after
knowing that as you point out one team
drafts for another player that you would
still keep on the board on your chlorine
in any way shape or form with the
graphic the team that had drafted him
even though we know he's playing for
another team it was so confusing to me
you know yeah I'm wondering if you've
spoken to the league about it or or or
if there's even
a thought about switching things we're
free agency would go first and then you
have the draft later on in the summer
you know I that part of it we have not
I've spoken this is my seventh year
doing the draft and I have talked to
them about why can't we get to a point
where you know it's post trade they call
it you know out I suggested maybe it's
the trade gets approved and then if for
some reason the numbers don't match up
because what what holds it up is to make
sure the trade is legal under the salary
cap that's what holds everything up and
it Dylan be a legal can go through the
trade and make sure it's not official so
in theory you know it could be that you
know a team takes a player with the
intention of sending them to the other
to the next destination and in theory
the league could say no no you can't do
that but we all know in reality that
even if they did say that but if that's
the way the draft work they would find a
way the teams would find a way to add
something to it to make it work so I I
have suggested so far not too much
available that we go ahead know what's
going to happen between traipsin agreed
to write and it's relatively within the
parameters of collective bargaining and
salary cap and all of that just let it
go you know it's dramatic yeah as you
well know when the NFL Commissioner goes
to the to the microphone and says
there's been a trade you know it brings
it brings a sense of anticipation to the
room and I can I can only imagine what
it would be like and the great
atmosphere that the NBA provides for
their draft every year so you know what
I think we need to do raises we as hosts
we've all got a band together and make
sure that leagues make the proper rules
changes to make our jobs as host a
palatable and easier to to up execute
Rhys don't you think maybe maybe earlier
my career I would have been more
adaptable now in my 50s rich I'm ready
for them to adapt to me a little bit
come on come on Commissioner silver
change around your league calendar to
make things easier for Rhys Davis to
hosted for seven straight
they do a great job of the grass but I
do wish that they would that they would
fix that and we're making a concerted
effort as one things we brought up today
to try to make it as clear as possible
when a guy is going to be on the move
you know I can remember several
instances over the last few years of you
know some guys standing there in a cap
for a team and doing the interview and
knowing that you know he's not going
there but there have also been a couple
of instances as I recall where sometimes
the guy didn't know that it was on the
move you know it's just still being it
was a likelihood and it's old he was
drafted and gone but most of the time
they say they know what's happening and
they know that they're on the move and
is it true that there there is a ban on
on tweeting from partners of the NBA
tonight before the pic is announced as
did I know that the league doesn't want
the picks tip now I do not know whether
that is an actual hard ban or not and I
think you know I might have even quoted
you on this I I agree with you from a
television standpoint now this is me
speaking personally this is not speaking
for ESPN or the league or anything else
so I made television standpoint I don't
want the tips picked on the television
but I could I could care less if
somebody or couldn't care less I guess
would be the proper English if someone
you know puts it out on Twitter I mean
sometimes I think would get a little too
much credence to that type of thing but
I know I know the league has been
sensitive to it because this is an
important night import of property for
them and you know they don't want the
the drama to be spoiled and I understand
that so a couple more minutes left with
rece Davis when do you think Grayson
Allen goes tonight where do you think
that happens I think he will don't late
first round I think you know Grayson is
a really good athlete what I understand
yet is sensational individual work out
where you did something absurd like make
80 or more out of a hundred NBA
three-pointers and you know the full
speed work now I think given the right
situation and put on the right team
obviously a lot of people speculated how
they would fit in Golden State and you
where he wouldn't be a focal point he
wouldn't be a centerpiece he would just
be another you know another guy who
could step in there and shoot a
situation like that I think would be
really really good for him something
that gets him off the ball and out of
the limelight a little bit but I think I
suspect that given his athleticism and
and shooting prowess and experience that
he'll be a late first round what about
the guy who broke my heart the big ragu
what about Dante D Vincenzo when does he
go tonight Reese I I think I think a
little higher than that I think mid
first round
probably not lottery but just below that
and I think that whoever gets him is
going to be very very happy i you know
billets now we're talking about last
yesterday on the ride over I commented I
said you know I really like Donovan
Mitchell at Louisville as a grant no
idea that he was going to be this good
and and he said that you know his friend
Quinn Schneider I told him that I think
the guy's gonna be Russell Westbrook and
and Billa said no I didn't teach I
thought it was good too but it would be
this good I'm not saying the jinjo is
going to be as good at Donovan Mitchell
but I do think he's going to be really
good he's a terrific athlete and you can
play a lot of different positions and
obviously great Street shooter and
veterans in the NBA get better at
shooting the ball typically and you know
Dave and chindan would hit a lot and
even extra maybe he didn't shoot it you
know quite accurately I think that will
just improve as he ages I think he's
going to be a really good I mean you use
the the Silence of the Lambs phrase
covet what you see I think that's gonna
I think he's gonna be as good as Donovan
Mitchell Reese based on what I saw and I
only said that because Donovan set the
bar so high horses lucky unexpectedly I
also think you're dying I'm very biased
toward the Michigan kids because having
done Big Ten games for a couple of years
I I can't think of a team in recent
memory that enjoyed being around more
than the team was no partner and
Muhammad Ali had dual Rahman and you
know all of those Michigan kids were
terrific
I think vogner is going to be two really
really good me and B as well he too will
become a more consistent you
you know nearly seven people watch
second round for him tonight is that
what you're hearing from all I think but
I'm gonna tell you I I wouldn't I think
there's somebody that takes a chance on
him right at the end of the first I
think that would not be an unwise move
I'm a big fan I really I really like Moe
and I think it's gonna be a good a good
Pro and I think you'd be worthy taken in
the first round but most projections
seem to say second round last one for
you Reese I'm switching sports I want to
give you the floor here because I
remember doing Sports Center with you
and when we would do highlights of
football and you would do give him six
you would say give him six and the man
who made that such a legendary phrase in
the hearts and minds of all Tennessee
volunteer fans John Ward the the
longtime voice of Tennessee football
passed away yesterday I want to give you
the floor and what he meant recently I
read when I was growing up even though I
grew up in Alabama and was obviously a
Crimson Tide fan I listen to every game
I possibly could and John Ward was an
iconic connection with one of the great
brands in college football and has had
the distinctive style
and you know the player was running and
he was counting down 5 4 3 2 1 and then
you know give him six touchdown big
orange and yeah he in an era when we
didn't get to see every game and see
every move the voices the play-by-play
voices of different schools they were
your connection and John Ward did that
brilliantly I love listening to him I
love the distinctive phrases that he
used and he had you know the old school
kind of a gravelly voice that was
perfect for Tennessee football and
certainly he left his marking and he'll
be missed and I look forward to the
dropping a couple of John Ward isms on
game day this year as a tribute to him I
know you've done we've done it for years
Reese I look forward to seeing you
tonight I will be I will have a chair
pulled up sir
look forward to it have a great cast
okay and those umpires alone and youth
baseball I was listening to your show I
was laughing my tail off because don't
feel badly I did the same thing
you're good and you're you're a saint
Rhys you're you're a saint so thank you
for backing my play in a way Davis the
Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern
on audience